bonjour atos et autres et fera un
plaisir pour moi d'être devant vous
aujourd'hui c'est toujours la main jean
des deux parties en dernier mais
nous sommes enchantés je suis né j'ai
fait mes premiers classe dans cette
commune qui accueille le tmx en séjour
comme quoi en revient toujours là où
tout a commencé dans la vie je n'ai pas
la prétention de vous enseigner une
quelconque méthode infaillible ni dois
de vous apprendre des choses innovantes
sur le team de la gestion optimale des
ressources humaines au vu des parts du
parterre de personnalités qui en face de
moi des entrepreneurs des hommes de
médias des dirigeants d'entreprises des
opinions et d'associations des personnes
travailleuses devant moi et je trouve
cela intimidant je voulais vous
cependant dans nos activités de tous les
jours
lorsqu'on a le choix entre les
ressources financières d'une part et les
ressources humaines et technologies
d'autre part on penche de manière
consciente ou inconsciente de pour le
choix de tout ce qui est ressources
financières c'est vrai cela est plus
simple sur les plus faciles mais ce
n'est pas toujours le meilleur levier de
développement de nos activités
professionnelles et associatif c'est
l'objectif de la dizaine de minutes que
nous allons partager ensemble en effet
comme je le disais tantôt depuis ma
naissance dans cette commune jusqu à
nouveau aujourd'hui dans cette commune
et 13 villes l'expérience que j'ai
accumulée have a permis de renforcer ma
conviction que les ressources humaines
et technologiques suffisent au
développement de toute activité humaine
et il est essentiel cette expérience est
forgée au cours de tout mon parcours
académique et professionnelle en effet
je suis né en côte d'ivoire dans la
commune de treichville
j'ai fait mes premières classes
primaires dans la commune 13 villes et
il fait d'ailleurs dans cette commune la
et au cours de mes classes primaires que
j'ai mon premier choc lorsque ma
maîtresse du prix mais ma fille mais que
la côte d'ivoire est un pays sous
développé et là c'était un choc terrible
et le choc était d'autant plus grand que
quand je voyais mon pays les grands
boulevards les immeubles le plateau les
belles voitures pour moi cela était
impossible et je suis rentré dans une
diatribe avec ma maîtresse à la maison
j'ai eu la confirmation comme quoi j'ai
eu la confirmation comme quoi la côte
d'ivoire un pays sous développé et là
c'est un choc mais cela a permis que je
puisse au seul a permis que je puisse
avoir
la volonté et le courage et les outils
nécessaires pour pouvoir changer les
choses et c'est en cela que comme
plusieurs personnes de la génération
actuelle et j'avais été conditionné par
le premier président de l'époque le
président vous vous éloignez avec sujet
d'eric là qui nous on était tout le
temps
et ce générique la conditionner beaucoup
de
beaucoup de personnes de ma génération à
l'agriculture et fait donc ce cadre là
que j'ai orienté mes études dès les
premières années dans une formation en
chimie biologie géologie pour essayer de
comprendre et de craquer le modèle
agricole ensuite par la suite avec les
premières années de formation je suis
rentré dans une formation dans le
domaine des mines et des titres parce
que la côte d'ivoire fait scandale
géologique
on a plusieurs à fleurs puis sion
guimier kir et qui ont un potentiel qui
est d'autant plus grand un potentiel
supérieur à celle du ghana et du mali et
je me suis dit que c'est là la région ce
qui pouvait nous permettre de sortie de
ce sous développement de sortie de cette
léthargie et ensuite après cela je me
suis orientée encore me spécialisant en
océanographie parce qu'avec toutes les
guerres de pétrole tout ce qu'on peut
voir comme conflit qui est lié à cette
ressource stratégique je me suis dit que
c'est là la clé et c'est là qui permet
aux pays arabes de se développer donc
pourquoi pas la côte d'ivoire après
toutes ces études là dans les ressources
minières dans les ressources agricoles
je me suis buté à la repère financier je
me suis dit que mais tu as beau avoir
les ressources tant d'autres a pas les
moyens financiers de pouvoir les
exploiter impossible c'est dans ce cadre
là que j'ai fait une étude de business
school et je suis allé en europe j'ai
fait des études en finances et je rentre
en banque parce qu'il banques qui dit
banque dit argent dit mobilisation des
ressources financières après 4 en banque
après avoir travaillé sur le rachat
d'orange par orange d'autres banques et
je me suis dit allez là avec des amis on
a assez de moyens on a un peu
d'expérience rentrons en côte d'ivoire
on a pu lever un peu d'argent et on va
lancer une start up qui va révolutionner
tout parce qu'on a la ressource
financière et on est capable de changer
des choses hélas après deux années
d'activité intense après avoir travaillé
d'arrache-pied des nuits blanches après
avoir communiqué dans tous les médias
qu'on eut éconduit deux ans après
l'échec beaucoup d'endettement et
ai-je été terrible mais on n'a pas pris
de nous le son directement la fougue de
la jeunesse on s'est dit ok on a les 20
millions d'euros 8,7 mais le plus
important c'est parce qu'on n'a pas
beaucoup lever quand tu lèves beaucoup
tu lèves assez tueur capable de
développer des choses je capable
d'acheter du marketing et pouvoir lancer
une activité ensuite à la suite de cet
échec là j'ai eu l'opportunité de
rejoindre un grand groupe que vous
connaissez johnny et qui est présent
pratiquement tous les pays d'afrique
avec quoi j'ai commencé dans le
débattement marketing où je gérais la
côte d'ivoire le sénégal et le cameroun
et la john y avait un paradigme
différent de toutes les start up et des
bases est vraiment sous les compétences
techniques et les ressources humaines en
prenant des gens d'une grande école de
commerce qui avait fait makine cbcg qui
avait roulé leur bosse dans plusieurs
structures et à côté d'eux il s'était
attaché des gens au niveau local qui
avait une grande expérience de terrain
qui avait fait de grandes études qui
avaient fait des meilleurs d'école la
côte d'ivoie avec une grande expérience
et une formation continue et le fait de
pouvoir associer ces deux pôles à a
permis à johnny de briller dès j'étais à
peu près toute la concurrence au niveau
de l'ue comme est plus de la côte
d'ivoire de sept autres pays en afrique
et a permis aussi d'être cotées à wall
street à de fins hype et auquel j'ai eu
la chance d'assister dans campant dans
ce pack ou là que j'ai fait dans cette
entreprise là quatre ans j'y suis
toujours cela a ma confiance et pour
vous me dis que mais c'est pas l'aspect
financier qui compte parce que c'est
johnny a levé un peu d'argent mais ça va
être comme beaucoup d'autres échecs sur
le continent africain et j'ai vu que le
psy qui a fait la différence je vous
l'avouer ce n'est pas l'aspect financier
c'est le fait d'avoir pris les
ressources humaines de qualité et les
mettre à la place qu'il fallait et
aujourd'hui je peux vous l'avouer vu
cette expérience là et vu mon expérience
dans le milieu associatif où j'ai dans
beaucoup de petits producteurs que
aujourd'hui le facteur humain et
technologie est la clé de toute chose et
et tout comme vous je suis sûr que
pendant vos études pendant vos échanges
les gens vous ont bassiné que les
ressources humaines sont la clé de toute
chose il faut aimer lambres et le
management de 360° la formation des
talents la rétention des talents tout à
plat nous plaidé reich auquel souvent
prête pas attention mais je peux vous le
dites vous le dire pendant mon
expérience en europe en afrique et si
toi johnny c'est vraiment cette
ressource humaine et s'est associé à
cette ressource technologique qui nous a
permis de mieux encadrer et d'optimiser
le potentiel réel des personnes et qui
nous a permis d'arriver là où sont en
gros on t'aime de notre échange de ce
partage d'expériences là je peux vous le
dis que si on veut vraiment que la côte
d'ivoire et l'afrique sur veut que nos
communautés se développe il est
véritablement important qu'on mette les
ressources humaines et technologiques
dans tout dans tout ce que nous faisons
et c'est là la clé du succès et je peux
vous le dis que au niveau des ressources
humaines je suis un type de partage
d'expérience on a deux choix on a le
premier choix qui est
soit d'être comme le real de madrid
temps d'utiliser les places construit
mais ou de partie fut une formation
continue avec le barça donc je dis
toujours real de madrid barça parce que
le real de madrid on prend des personnes
confirmées des personnes qui ont roulé
leur bosse partout qu'ils ont reçue que
ce sont des personnes près top avec ces
personnes là tu peux développer tout ce
que tu veux tu peux lever des fonds
comme tu veux tu peux accéder à des
grandes richesses ou bien tu vas sur la
formation en prenant des talents et en
les formant ou en faisant des mx1 mx2 et
l'idéal le rêve tout le monde sait à
voix en fait des players confirmés et
des personnes qui ont un potentiel
énorme et c'est ce qui fait la bonne
mayonnaise en gros les bonnes personnes
aux bonnes places qui convient sacré 90%
de ton business et
et cela permettra aux personnes d'avoir
les dirigeants de conseiller des
dirigeants de qualité et je peux vous le
dire qu'aujourd'hui si on me présentant
des ressources financières illimitées
vers 6 des personnes telles que les plus
comme il est noté les daouda au niveau
local je préfère vraiment ses ressources
humaines là et technologique parce que
ces ressources humaines et
technologiques sont capables de
mobiliser des ressources financières de
mobiliser des compétences et avec leur
grande expérience permet de gagner
vraiment du temps en évitant sets à zéro
même à priay et mon voeu le plus cher
c'est qu'on n'oublie jamais que le
facteur x dans toutes entreprises dans
toute association dans tout projet de
notre vie de tous les jours c'est
l'humain et la technologie merci
[Applaudissements]